an extensive survey of Yale's incoming
freshman class has found that the class
of 2022 will be quote the most diverse
in university history
there'll be 5% homosexual 9% bisexual or
transsexual 8% asexual and 3% unwilling
to answer the question which sounds
pretty quois sexual to me also they're
all leftists we will analyze the
increasingly homogenous diversity on
campus and what can be done about it
then speaking of diversity the Dalai
Lama defends nationalism in Europe drink
up folks and Twitter bans old speak
finally the mailbag I'm Michel Knowles
and this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
by the way I'd like to make a correction
I'm sorry I how insensitive of me I use
the word freshmen to describe the
incoming class obviously fresh man is a
sexist term so I should say fresh person
well
well except of course that son is a
sexist term too so I guess it should be
fresh per daughter the Fred the Yale
fresh / daughter class will analyze the
incoming fresh bird otter class but
first I've got to thank our sponsor at
thrive market oh we thrive is really
good thrive yeah you know I'm a man of
simple tastes I'm easily satisfied by
the best thrive market will give you the
best go there right now thrive market
calm / michael mi CH AE l thrive market
is a revolutionary online marketplace on
a mission to make healthy living easy
and affordable for everyone
you can shop for thousands of the best
selling non-gmo foods and natural
products always a twenty five to fifty
percent below traditional retail prices
the reason I wouldn't buy all that
really good quality food in the past is
because I'm a cheapskate so I you know
especially when I was a bachelor I would
just you know eat whatever muck out of
the gutter that I could find but when
you can get it at a really good price
because thrive market sells directly to
you you'll get the highest quality
ingredients at even more affordable
prices than the current premium products
carried everywhere so you get non-gmo
food snacks vitamins all that stuff I
love their olive oil is really I use a
ton of their stuff I use them all the
time
but especially their olive oil is really
really good you will love it
more than 70% of the thrive market
catalog can't be find on Amazon right
now get 60% of free organic groceries
press Plus free shipping and a 30-day
trial so hey look you'll get some free
groceries that's pretty good man you do
it now you'd be a fool not to you have
twenty bucks off your first three orders
of forty-nine dollars or more plus free
shipping most shoppers will spend more
than that anyway because they've such
good stuff so you will automatically get
back $20 so your total purchase becomes
30 per per deal you get this deal three
times in a row thrive market calm /
Michael MSH AEL get instant $60 of free
groceries thrive market dot-com /
Michael okay we've got a ton of stuff to
get to today so we got to get right into
it
a lot of chakras are going out of
alignment today a lot of you can do here
it happening all the crystals in the
chakras just going at a lot of people
they were doing their Sun Salutations
now they're doing downward-facing dog
because the Dali Lama is defending
nationalism in Europe this is a
beautiful thing it's one of those news
stories where do I care what the Dalai
Lama says not really do I even care that
much about what's going on in European
politics not really but when these
things align up like this it is just too
good because every little hippie dippie
unshowered you know wild-haired weirdo
walking around Los Angeles with their
Bernie bumper stickers on is now gonna
be very upset they all do yoga yoga has
become the the Church of Millennials and
the Dalai Lama defending nationalism
which makes perfect sense he probably
was listening to our show yesterday and
that's why he did it because we've been
talking about nationalism now for a
couple of days and and by the way if
that I don't know if the Dalai Lama is
looking for a new job but my own church
the Catholic Church could use some new
bishops and it sounds like this guy's at
least right about a few things so and
maybe it consider applying the Dalai
Lama was a conference in Sweden
yesterday this was three days after the
right wing party in Sweden which is
called the Sweden Democrats I see why
that's confusing but they're the right
wing party there they did very well in
the general elections and so he was
speaking in Sweden and I think that left
was expecting him to say look for reject
right-wing politics didn't open borders
man come on let's all you know kumbaya
but he didn't say that he said quote
Europe belongs to the Europeans receive
them help them educate them but
ultimately they should develop their own
country with regard to the Islamic
refugees the immigrants who are over
there
Europe belongs to the Europeans this is
a truism this shouldn't be a
controversial statement of course that's
true
Europe belongs to the Europeans America
belongs to the Americans China belongs
to the Chinese why that that is the Nick
the definition of the nation but now to
say that is controversial it's seen as
racist I don't know how it's racist
there are a lot of different races in
Europe but somehow that's considered
racist now because you have floods and
floods of Islamic migrants coming across
borders in Europe and flooding these
countries in many cases invading these
countries with the protection of the
European Union with the encouragement of
the European
Union there was that great book on it
the strange death of Europe by Douglas
Murray I think it came out a little
while ago excellent book on this topic
talks about whole Italian towns being
overrun by Islamic migrants coming
across borders and what the Dalai Lama
is defending here is the right of
European nations to remain European
nations I get why the left is surprised
by this because the Dalai Lama is a cool
like hippie dippie guy if anybody's
gonna be a nationalist it's gonna be the
Dalai Lama he has been fighting for the
right of the nation of Tibet against the
imperial encroachments of China for all
of our lifetimes he went on he said
quote I think Europe belongs to the
Europeans they ultimately should rebuild
their own country and he said by the way
this wasn't just a reaction to Trump
it's not like he is playing some
political game and you say oh I see
Trump is popular okay I'll mimic him in
2016 before Donald Trump was elected the
Dalai Lama said quote Europe for example
Germany cannot become an Arab country
Germany is Germany there are so many
that in practice it becomes difficult
meaning there are so many migrants
coming across the border he said as we
all feel when we look into the face of
every single refugee especially the
children and women we can feel their
suffering and therefore we should help
them of course we should help them the
goal however should be that they return
and help rebuild their countries end
quote
that again should not be controversial
when we're talking about refugees why
would we have refugees come over from a
totally foreign region of the world to a
totally foreign region of the world
rather than people within their own
neighborhoods helping to take care of
them
why wouldn't we want to rebuild those
countries perhaps there is a problem in
certain cultures there perhaps there are
conflicts among cultures over there why
would we import wholesale unvetted those
sort of cultural problems this is this
used to be a progressive position this
used to be a accepted by the left and
the right because in the old days you
had imperialism and then in the wake of
the Second World War
we we had a surge of nationalism India
becomes a nation the countries in the
Middle East get to become their own
nations countries in Africa
this was the height of freedom because
the nation can protect Liberty for
individuals for communities for
different groups without descending into
anarchy on the one hand or becoming
oppressive and imperial on the other
hand so I understand that the orthodoxy
of the left right now is that we need to
become one world government under a
totally benevolent Empire oh it'll be
different this time it'll be totally
benevolent but perhaps the left should
look to some of the people that for a
long time it's admired like Dalai Lama
to see where they've gone so so wrong
and in the meantime we can fill up our
leftist ears so the Dalai Lama is on one
side of that Twitter is now on the other
Twitter banned the phrase in its
advertising platform it banned the
phrase illegal alien because that's hate
speech that's hateful content now you
can't say illegal alien illegal alien is
not a hateful phrase illegal alien is
the precise technical term for illegal
aliens that all the other things are
euphemisms dreamer undocumented future
whatever that that those are euphemisms
that don't precisely describe what we're
talking about illegal alien does but
Twitter doesn't care to Jack Dorsey the
head of Twitter basically admitted to
shadow banning six hundred thousand
accounts because Twitter is an
international company abused itself as
an international company it doesn't have
bonds of national loyalty when the right
and the left at various points complain
about multinational corporations they do
have one point which is that these super
national extra transnational
organizations don't have the same
priorities that you and I do because
they don't have current loyalty to
communities in two states in two
countries they're they're bigger than
that and this brings us to the Yale of
it all because Gail calls itself even in
recent years even when I was there they
call it themselves a global University
not an American University a global
University the catch phrase for Yale
used to be for God for country and for
Yale in that order but now that it's not
the case now it is an International
University it touts all the time how
many foreign international students are
coming in there and always trying to
increase that number in part because
they pay a lot of money to go and there
was a magazine when I was there I think
it still exists called the Yale Global
that was and that was the very
fashionable magazine to write for as an
undergraduate and now they talk about
the most diverse class ever and you say
oh good oh thank goodness because all
I'm hearing is this one point of view
this one perspective the global
university the globalist the left-wing
progressive oh good now we have some
diversity what diversity do we get so
when it comes to sexual diversity the
old line at Yale was one in four maybe
more for gay students and now the
numbers are almost exactly that in terms
of students who are not straight of
students who have more creative sexual
preferences if the number actually is
close to one in four this is no surprise
this is going on a long time you know
Yale did turn out Cole Porter I think
American Psycho said that that Yale
thing is when you have either repressed
homosexuality or a cocaine addiction
maybe both I don't know but when it when
you get down to intellectual diversity
ideological philosophical diversity this
this wide-ranging study found that just
9% of Yale incoming students consider
themselves somewhat conservative and
just 2% consider themselves very
conservative and let me translate that
for you haven't been familiar with how
this goes somewhat conservative at Yale
means that you don't think that Mitt
Romney is Hitler that's that's what's
somewhat conservative means very
conservative means I don't know that you
registered as a Republican at 18 I think
that probably counts it you know you
have some you have a an American flag
bowtie or something that that's like
very very conservative and so we're
talking about 2% of pretty serious
conservatives there there is very little
intellectual diversity same thing on the
faculty I saw some conservative faculty
members or would-be faculty members get
run out of town a 2016 survey by the
Yale Daily News shows that 95 percent of
conservative students felt that their
views were unwelcome at Yale and I don't
want to beat up on Yale too much but the
reason that this is a national story is
that Yale is representative not just of
some school in New Haven but of all of
these campuses across the country with a
very few exceptions they are all being
overrun by the left they're all
indoctrinated rather
and educating to increasing degrees and
we've got to find a way to stop this you
remember you know you the craziness that
kind of typifies the craziness on all
campuses but it really was most
prevalent I think at dear old New Haven
was shrieking girl they came out a few
years ago just to refresh your memory
and because I need a little refill on my
tumblr
take it away shrieking part of this
video it's a very distressing video but
my favorite part is that guy at the end
the advocate guy because you know he was
just standing there everyone's yelling
everyone's strings like alright Johnny
this is your chance this is your chance
to finally watch well what am i oh I'll
say yeah that he was supposed to be our
advocate all right everyone's talking
all right here you were supposed to be
all right but uh nobody's talking
anymore oh it's so embarrassing so
awkward and the girl this girl should
have been expelled right Geralyn Luther
should have been expelled for this that
is so horrific ly disrespectful all of
the students involved screaming at their
professor should have been expelled on
the spot what happened instead the
students who led this revolt on campus
were given awards at their graduation
they were given awards this is a really
horrifying turn of events you're seeing
the American University not just at Yale
but all around the country imploding and
we're very lucky because there is a guy
who is running for the Yale Board of
Trustees on a campaign to turn this
around to make sure that events like
this never happen again not at Yale and
hopefully this can be a signal to all of
the
universities around the country to stop
this Jamie Couric is an American
reporter foreign correspondent candidate
for the Yale Board of Trustees I spoke
to him last week here's Jamie Jamie
thank you so much for being here thanks
for having me so Jamie obviously I feel
a personal connection to your campaign
because you're running for the Yale
corporation for the Yale Board of
Trustees but I think your campaign and
the issues you're talking about actually
reflect a national trend that's going on
on colleges that's going on at
universities across the country oh why
are you running for the Yale Board of
Trustees well like you say I think our
university to play a major role in
educating future leaders and Yale in
particular in the Ivy League and a lot
of the ideas that come out of
universities that become popular and
universities eventually seep their way
into the general public and I think over
the past couple of years we've seen at
Yale and many other universities growing
in tolerance for differing viewpoints
and not necessarily conservative
viewpoints by the way I mean the clip
that you just showed you know it wasn't
a right wing professor being yelled at
it was a liberal one so things are I
think getting out of hand you know just
two weeks ago we had this huge or last
week excuse me this huge controversy
with The New Yorker canceling an
interview with with Steve Bannon I'm no
fan of Steve Ben and I have criticized
him many times in print but to pretend
that you know he or his ideas you know
don't exist another not influential and
they actually haven't been used to win
elections and major countries across the
Western world you know from a left-wing
perspective I don't see how that
actually helps you to just sort of put
your fingers in your ears and pretend
that these things don't exist and wish
them to go away so I've been really
disappointed that what I see is the kind
of climate of growing intellectual
intolerance on the under Yale campus in
particular but also across the country
and I think that you know alumni of
these institutions really need to try to
exercise some more influence because
they're really the only part they're the
only constituency of the university I
think has any chances of fixing this
that's absolutely right when a few years
ago when we saw that clip from Yale
the girl you know this is not an
intellectual space this is not a home
and you know shrieking at her making
profanity at her professor you've seen
this happen so many other places as well
one thing I love about your candidacy is
that you're not some rock-ribbed
conservative I don't think you're a
hard-line Republican in your own way
and yet you're you're reflective of this
view now in the center and among
independents and reasonable minded
people that even if I disagree with
speech we should permit free speech
especially on a campus right yeah no I
mean I'm probably the center maybe
vaguely center-right politically I voted
for Hillary Clinton I'm endorsed so just
to give your listeners an idea I'm will
forgiving I've lived over season um like
I've lived overseas I lived in you know
other democratic countries that don't
have the same culture of free speech
that the United States does and I really
just come to appreciate how lucky we are
and of course you know I do we hear
things that we don't like absolutely you
know Alex Jones is sort of the cost of
free speech it's the crazy homeless guy
you know shouting you know curses at you
as you as you go to work but you have to
put up with that you can't just put the
homeless guy in prison for screaming
something that you don't like and so I
really am an absolutist when it when it
comes to this I think it's a small L
liberal position I think it's a position
that frankly throughout history it's
usually been people on the Left whose
free speech has been quashed I mean if
you go back to you know the the Palmer
Raids afterworld around World War One
car theism the various you know very
controversial art exhibitions that were
put up during the 80s and 90s it's
usually people on the left but now I
think that the left has basically come
to dominate media academia cultural
institutions they've now come to
dominate these institutions they are now
in absolute total control and I it's
just unfortunate to see that they
haven't really learned the lessons that
you know when they were in need of
people to defend their free speech
they're now completely flipped that's
examined and they're going after anyone
yeah yeah
well if a university doesn't have the
free exchange of ideas then where is
going to have a free exchange of ideas
you know I'm sure people are looking at
your candidacy and they're saying what
can we do what can we do to help bring
the universities and liberal education
back from the brink so my question is
two parts one what will you do when
you're on the Yale corporation board and
what can other people do who are alumni
of other universities or who are at
other universities to try to stop all
the censorship stop the screaming stop
the degradation of the liberal education
culture and actually reclaim the free
exchange of ideas I think the
universities need to stop putting up
basically kicked me signs on their backs
and they need to make it very clear the
administrators need to make it very
clear to incoming freshman you know
these are our values we believe in free
speech aren't going to be you're happy
to be shouting down speakers and so
there's a very excellent letter that was
you know written by believe the Dean of
Students at the University of Chicago
and it was sent out to every incoming
freshman and it's very it's very blunt
and it says there's no there's no
trigger warnings there's no stage spaces
this is a place for intellectual
development and debate I think students
coming to Chicago they already
understand this and if they if they
really don't like it then they're not
going to go to Chicago and so I really
would like to see one you know if I'm um
if I'm elected to the board I would I
would urge the president of Yale the
Dean of Students to send out similar
letters Yale actually has an excellent
policy on this Woodward report it was
published in 1974 after some very
high-profile controversial speakers and
and and riots grew up around that the
university commissioned this report and
it's really looked and cited upon as
being one of the best expressions in
defense of free speech in an academic
setting I would send that to every
incoming freshman perhaps there's a
program that Princeton has where they
assign all the incoming freshmen to
books that are basically you know pro
and con on a very contentious subject
like abortion say a book that's in favor
of abortion rights and one that is
against it and all the incoming freshmen
no matter what they're majoring in even
if they're going to be majoring in you
know
astronomy or whatever they they have to
read these books and will be a classroom
discussion about it just to sort of get
them in in the mood and to inculcate
these values so those are some of the
ideas that I've brought forth and then
you know for me personally I'd love it
if your listeners if they know people
who went to Yale they did go to Yale go
to the website Jamie for trusty comm
they can sign sign my petition to get me
on the ballot and I would just encourage
people you know most universities they
have similar bodies like the Yale
corporation they have boards of trustees
they have governing bodies on which
alumni sit and play a role so that's you
know do what I'm doing run run to be on
the board of trustees you can also
frankly put your money where your mouth
is and if the university that you are an
alum of is not you know behaving or not
not defending Enlightenment values like
you want them to and make it clear to
the financial office the giving office
that you're not going to be donating
anymore and that's ultimately what might
have to happen in order for you know
real serious positive change to take
place that that is such a good point I
love it when the fundraising committee
calls me and they ask for my annual $20
that I donate to dear old Yale and and I
say no you're not getting it this year
shut down the programs and I go on my
long lecture because you see this at a
lot of institutions even outside of
education you hear a get woke go broke
people are really they don't want this
oppressive censorious politics of
division shoved in their face all the
time and so I hope it's very important
if you do know anybody who went to Yale
or is it Yale or whatever make sure you
go to Jamie for trustee calm because I
think this is going to send a message
nationally you mentioned you Chicago
they had a great statement on free
speech Purdue University under mitch
Daniels had a great statement on free
speech and Yale is not living up to the
Woodward report they're not defending
free speech so I wonder you know when
when the right sort of lost any
influence at all at universities they
started think tanks there are other
alternatives to traditional four-year
college degrees
are we going to see a shift away if the
colleges remain totally opposed to free
ideas politicized increasingly
ideological majors are we gonna see some
new competing form of education crop up
or are we consign to just this left-wing
malaise that's going to get worse and
worse and and more since aureus as time
goes on I think we're already seeing
perhaps the early development of this
one in sort of the formation of this
hetero Dobbs Academy and this whole
intellectual dark web and people are
seeming to you know there's clearly a
lot of interest in this and a lot of
people are kind of becoming autodidact
you know and they're educating
themselves outside of the traditional
university structures the other
development that I would say indicates
it's something that used to just might
be happening is we're seeing a lot of
Millennials you know leave college with
these are very expensive four-year
degrees in various you know very obscure
subjects and they're not getting jobs
and they're living with their parents
and I think it's eventually going to
dawn on people that the education that
they're getting in some of these schools
are just not marketable in a free
society perhaps this is one of the
reasons why Millennials are increasingly
attracted toward socialism because
they're not making this connection
they're not making this connection in
their head they feel very aggrieved and
resentful that you know the four-year
degree that they got in performative
puppetry or whatever is not translating
into a hundred thousand dollar a year
job right out of school and so rather
than say well maybe I shouldn't have
gotten this useless degree perhaps I you
know I'm gonna blame society and I'm
gonna demand you know socialism and free
education and free this and free that so
I think we're already seeing the sort of
the understanding that something is off
that you know Peter Thiel has referred
to a higher education bubble I think
there is something like that going on
and you know if it's going to explode or
how that's going to develop is you know
anyone's guess well as a transformative
puppetry minor I have to tell you the
job market was really tough on me when I
got out of dear old college I noticed
that you have you seem to have done well
for yourself
yeah well the key was that I didn't
write a book that was the real it was
the one
good idea I had I noticed you have very
strange-looking wallpaper behind you
that's because you're coming to us from
the middle of nowhere somewhere on the
other side of the earth I'm at I'm at a
conference in the nation of Georgia it's
not the US stage it's about ten years
ago just last month you'll remember was
invaded and occupied by by Russia 20% of
its territory so they come here every
year for a conference I think it's a
very it's a great country great people
freedom-loving very pro-american very
westward looking and I always try to
come to this conference every year to
really remind myself what America's role
in the world should be so what what
freedom means more important now than
ever before perhaps so Jaime I'm gonna
let you go I know it's about midnight
over there where you are so go keep it
up if you are a lino yaly go to Jamie
for trustee calm and help out try to
spur similar campaigns at your college
at your University because that's the
only way we're gonna restore some sanity
to the campuses Jamie thanks so much for
being here thanks for having me
alright we've got a lot more to get to
I'm finally leaving enough time to do
the mailbag I always don't leave enough
time and then there are like five
minutes left and I speed through them
but I'm finally leaving enough time so
go to daily wired.com if you're on
facebook and youtube i'm shocked to hear
it if you're on Daily wire thank you
help us keep the lights on in Co FFA in
my cup go over there it's ten bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership what
do you get
what don't you get what don't you get
these days you get me you get the under
Clavin sure you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get the Matt Walsh show you get to
ask questions in the mailbag which is
coming up you get to ask questions in
the conversation the big boss Ben
Shapiro is coming up this month I
believe and none of that matters because
you get this special Dali Lama edition
of leftist tears he's causing them he's
not the one producing them do you
remember I think it was about 20 years
ago when the Dalai Lama did a Rolex ad
you know he was wearing a Rolex or
something this is this is the new
conspicuous consumption piece that you
need the leftist here's tumbler we
should do like a gold-plated one or
something like that go get it it's the
only fda-approved vessel of salty
delicious left as tears which we're
gonna get a lot of
Jamie wins Thank You Board of Trustees
which is just a lovely thing it's a
lovely thing when sort of people in the
centre liberals center left center right
when they are like considered to the
right of Genghis Khan which is the
culture that we're in though
excuse me go to daily wear calm we'll be
right back with the mailbag
[Music]
jumping right em from Nathan hey Michael
a few weeks ago you suggested I start
reading CS Louis with mere Christianity
and I'm about done with it incredible
read so far there is one part I wanted
to ask your opinion on in his section on
pride he talks about looking down on
people making it impossible to look up
toward God does God really expect us to
look down on no one is it really conceit
'fl to think I am better than a person
who skin's 30 people alive and then
sleeps soundly
or that I'm better than the person I was
in the past it seems to me that if we
can't think our selves superior to at
least some others without the sin of
pride the concept of trying to be a good
person loses meaning I see why this is
confusing I have a solution the issue
here is not that you should think less
of yourself it's that you should think
of yourself less and that will solve the
problem if you're sitting there thinking
or thinking well how should I think
about me and how should I think about my
relation to other people and where I am
in the pecking order of the hierarchy of
people you're doing it wrong pride is
the queen of all sins this is the
hardest one to root out because it is
the essential sin it is the the original
sin the the cause of the original sin is
pride wanting to elevate yourself
thinking of yourself a man wrapped up in
himself makes a very small package
indeed it was the fall of Satan of
Lucifer from heaven it's so insidious is
always waiting there for you and you
know the more humble you think you've
become the more prideful you'll be in
your humility so the key is to think of
yourself less think about other people
more think of yourself less you will
have a better life we all fall into
pride from time to time but pride will
make you miserable the more you think
about yourself you think it's gonna make
you happy because you feel really good
you think oh you know I I hit a home run
today in baseball that never happened to
me obviously but you know you think I'm
really cool I'm a real cool guy and the
more you do that the more miserable
you'll be the less you think about
yourself the more joyful you'll be
from Ryan I'm a Catholic and I feel that
pledging allegiance to the flag is
idolatrous as a result I feel that I
shouldn't say the Pledge or place my
hand over my heart
I do love my country but my allegiance
is only to God can you explain why this
is permissible love this show
absolutely the pledge of allegiance is a
wonderful thing do you have any
allegiance to your wife you have any
allegiance to your parents or your kids
or your family or your community do you
have any ally of course we have loyalty
to many different things and not not all
equally you know I have a loyalty to my
broom closet you know this is my
community here that I'm locked up in all
day and of course everybody has a
loyalty to your family to your community
to your state to your country and
ultimately to God that's perfectly fine
it's only a crazy rationalism that makes
us pretend that we can only be loyal to
one thing you know Christ tells us in
Scripture that you unless you hate your
father and your mother and your family
you can't follow him but God also tells
us that husbands should love their wives
how do you resolve these things
rationalists want to pick one or the
other but what both are doing is telling
us a spiritual truth we have many
loyalties and allegiances but we have to
keep them in the proper order and our
pledge of allegiance is a wonderful
expression of that because our pledge of
allegiance keeps it in order we pledge
allegiance to one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all we actually clarified it in 1954 to
add in under God to make it clear that
we're not committing some heresy or
making an idol out of our nation but
that we have a natural loyalty to our
communities and clans and you know
groupings and ultimately into the nation
and all of that is under God and America
has been guided so clearly by Providence
since her very beginning that it's a
wonderful thing to pledge allegiance and
to know that all of that allegiance is
ordered and under and looking up to God
from Nathan a lot of Nathan's coming in
today hey Michael equestria that free
will how do you square the concepts of
an omniscient God and me having free
choice both are fundamental to our
religion but I don't see how I can have
real
unless God does not know what I'm going
to do next for example Judas Iscariot
needed to betray Christ in the order for
the crucifixion to take place Christ
said he knew about it beforehand so
could you Judas have chosen to do
otherwise did God create Judas knowing
for certain he would go to hell or
Pontius Pilate for that matter because
then he would know for all of us and my
choices can't change anything any advice
god bless yes all of heresy comes from
impatience with mystery I think just
about all of it comes from that it comes
from not being able to resolve how God
can have a perfect justice and perfect
mercy how we can have a there can be
perfect grace and perfect freewill and
so what happens is people who want to
rationalize their way out of that pick
one or the other but it isn't one or the
other
Thomas Aquinas could give you a much
better version of this than I could and
there isn't enough time to go into it
but I'll give you a little trick or a
shortcut on this which is the question
of time and space this this I I never
really understood the confusion on
freewill and be omniscience of God
because God is outside of time and space
and I'm inside of time and space so I'm
here in time and space and I have my
free choice and I'm choosing to do
things but from the perspective outside
of time and space you see all those
choices as having already happened even
my language is misleading here because
I'm speaking in tenses that have to do
with time and we're talking about
something outside of time but those are
different perspectives the perspective
of being inside of time and space and
the perspective of being outside of it
those of those can simultaneously be
true I can live my life freely and have
free choice and have free will and
someone who is outside of time can see
what has happened what is happening and
what will happen all at the same time
outside of which he is this came into
great confusion during the Protestant
revolution
you know I criticize Martin Luther a
little bit on the show on occasion this
time it's no different Luther and Calvin
both came down on the side that there is
no such thing as free will they denied
free will Luther in his writings
disagreeing with Erasmus and John Calvin
in his doctrine of predestination
but human freedom is very very important
it is the the central fact that that we
have here that we are in possession of
that leads to our happiness in the world
free choices what caused the fall and
forget you you're talking about how it
caused Judas
you know God knew that Judas would
betray him but go all the way back to
the fall God knew that Adam would sin
God knew that mankind would fall and
because of Adams free will
we had the fall and because of the fall
we got the Incarnation because of the
Incarnation we got the crucifixion and
we got the resurrection we got the happy
fall we got a wonderful joy the greatest
story ever told the greatest possible
world that's because we have free will
and because of the grace of God you see
this in the Incarnation when the angel
comes down it says to Mary hail Mary
full of grace you will conceive a child
even though you haven't known a man you
will conceive a child and and you are
blessed and that was the grace God comes
down the mountain you see all of this
grace but then Mary consents to it she
says I am The Lord's servant let it be
done according to your word she can all
of Heaven is holding its breath God and
His omniscience knew what she was going
to say but she still has that
opportunity to ascend to turn toward God
or turn away from God and we can do that
all of the time and just because someone
outside of the perspective of time knows
what you're going to do doesn't mean
that you aren't really doing it from Bob
hi Michael I'm an atheist and support
abortion within the first trimester or
beyond it given the rise of specific
circumstances
case in point personal friend decided on
an abortion when she learned that a
medication she was temporarily taking
caused birth deformities she was married
at the time and later conceived and gave
birth to healthy properly developed
babies would you have preferred to see
her forced to carry to term a malformed
child well I would prefer if she didn't
kill the child yeah because nobody's
perfect are you perfect are you were you
properly formed I've given your question
I wonder if you were properly formed
what do you mean perfect what baby is
perfect
should we now went so you're saying the
baby had a deformity let's say it was
missing a finger or something should we
should we kill babies that don't have
fingers should we kill adults who are
missing a finger what if the baby has
Down syndrome should we kill people with
Down syndrome plenty of villains
throughout history have killed mentally
[ __ ] people people with mental
deficiencies is that what you suggest we
do it what about physical ones what I'm
not a great athlete should what should I
be wiped out maybe my mother could have
tried again the doctor could have looked
in and said oh you know he's okay he's
got really poufy hair you should have
nice oily swarthy skin but he's not
gonna be much of an athlete he's gonna
be pretty slow and you know he'll
probably strike out most times in
baseball just say okay get like get rid
of him we'll try again is that it nobody
suggests that nobody thinks we should do
that you've got to follow the logic of
these to their logical conclusion if we
were perfect if we were all perfect then
maybe there would be something to your
argument but then you wouldn't have an
argument at all and then this we live in
a fallen world and getting back to that
first question we talked about perhaps
we should stop thinking so much of
ourselves and start looking at our own
deficiencies and and therefore having a
little more grace for other people from
where from Benjamin from Benjamin hey
Michael I am in week three of my first
semester at a very left-wing college
here in California I'm going to begin to
bring my leftist tears tumbler to school
so I can sip on Co FFA to keep me awake
during my 8:00 a.m. class if that's so
good I love it
if a classmate presumably a lefty asks
me about my tumblr how would you respond
so I can keep a potential friendship
while explaining the wonders of this
tumblr thanks Benjamin this is a win win
you've put yourself in a win-win
scenario you're sitting there in class
day little you take a little dalai lama
step and your classmate comes up to you
and says what's that your answer has to
be this is a leftist here's tumblr and
if the person has a sense of humor left
or right they would laugh and say ha ha
ha that's pretty funny if they don't
have a sense of humor you probably don't
want to be friends with them anyway and
you'll get a free refill of your leftist
tears this is the perfect scenario to
Veon i how if only i could go back to
college what a great time that was we
still have a little bit of time I'm
gonna go through a few more from
Veronica
hey Mikey poo hey Veronica Ron Ron how
you doing I would like the inside scoop
on how to do New York City I want to see
cool things but avoid crowds and
tourists and I would like to not go
broke sorry
go to Chicago do you want me to tell you
give me the ultimate guide to the Big
Apple if you're really from there since
there's an epidemic of people lying
about their origins these days I'm as I
was actually born in Kenya so okay I
hope to tell you about that thanks doll
yeah you bet thanks Veronica
so you're there's no way to do New York
without going broke
it's an expensive place and there's a
lot of fun stuff to do so just do it one
thing you can do and you also can't have
all you want to avoid the crowds you
don't want to go broke you want man that
though you can't do all those together
the cheapest thing you can do that's
pretty cool it's very early in the
morning get on the Staten Island Ferry
and you will get a free view of the
Statue of Liberty it is zero dollars to
get on there will be a crowd but it's
pretty cool I used to do it back in my
heart or partying days I would after a
nice long night of going out on the town
having a couple adult beverages some
friends and I would get on the Staten
Island Ferry right at sunrise and you
get to see the Sun Rise you get to see
the Statue of Liberty you get to go eat
a sandwich in Staten Island and then
immediately get back on the Staten
Island Ferry you know go back and so
that's a fun thing to do it's always bad
to ask a New Yorker what to do in New
York because I've I've lived in New York
for most of my life in the city outside
the city around you know nearby I've
never been to the Empire State Building
I have never I have not been in the New
World Trade Center building even though
I lived a block away from it I had never
been inside the old World Trade Center
the Twin Towers
I've never been to the Statue of Liberty
Island never gone there never done a
carriage ride and you know all the
things that the tourists want to do none
of us ever ever do there
so my recommendation I'm just gonna I'm
gonna give you what I do when I go to
New York and take it for what it's worth
I always I go to the great cigar bars
cigar in on 50
and second Kornegay club it's a little
pricier but they have a great centrist
Saturday I'll go to Keens Steakhouse
it's the greatest steakhouse in the
world then if you want a bagel early in
the morning go down to Leo's downtown
it's by the World Trade Center and
there's a great boozy brunch at Harry's
Steakhouse down there and the finest bar
in all of New York the most degenerate
disgusting despicable den of debauchery
is the iron horse on Fulton what is a
Fulton and cliff I think they used to
like the bar on fire a couple times a
night I think now they've stopped doing
that but you know they have like a pool
table and mean-looking biker dudes and
it's just terrific it's a great time
it's great to walk in there and you're a
little like polo shirt at Oxford you
know the loafers hey fellas how you
doing great bar do that let me know it
how you enjoyed it
from Austin dear Archangel Michael
look-alike not it not after a night at
the Iron Horse let me tell you that
defender of conservatism protector of
the Ben Shapiro show broom closet I
require your expertise in relationships
bring it on I've been single for awhile
about two years and it found myself
falling for two women one is currently
in the Navy Academy and the other is
pursuing education to become a
psychiatrist I hold both as close
friends and care for both of them
equally I am at the point where I want
to date for marriage and not just for a
hooker I live in Pennsylvania so I won't
be able to see the girl in the Navy
Academy much but the psychiatrist to be
has a few extracurricular activities
that I'm not entirely kosher with pot
the OL Haitian oregano but she lives
just a short drive away thanks for all
your help
you are truly deserving of the title
cousin of the daily wire much-loved
Austin but I don't know so this is a
I'll give you my advice trying to
calibrate how much I can say you always
want to be honest you want to be you
don't want to be a jerk about dating
girls but if you're not sure who you
want to date then you should spend a
little time with both girls you know
being honest they'll go to dinner or get
that you know kind of get to know you
don't I don't know your age if you're 18
or something you don't have to make a
decision right away I I don't know
enough about the girl
so I mean all I know is one girl's going
on Naval Academy that's great good good
honor and the other girls a psychiatrist
I've always had a preference for
psychiatrists the pot thing I don't know
if she's in college that could pass by
you know I mean who knows in the culture
now marijuana is becoming a sacrament so
perhaps perhaps we'll all end up puffing
on the old Haitian oregano
I prefer coffe FA but you it's all it's
about the girls you know I gave this
advice to some other guy you got to tell
me about the person don't don't date
someone or marry someone because of
their job or how much money they're
gonna make or if they're gonna travel or
whatever you know because they like to
smoke pot when they're 18 it's it's
about the person and that's ineffable I
can't tell you about that the way that
you can find that out though is by
talking to the girls honestly you know
being interested in what they have to do
trying to learn about them trying to get
a sense of them and seeing what clicks
because there is a little chemistry this
isn't so clinical I know now we're in
the swipe culture but colporteur didn't
sing let's do it let's be in a an
exclusive relationship after we date for
a little while because we swiped right
on tinder that's not what he said it's
and let's do it let's fall in love so
you that's the that's really what you've
got to focus on a little bit just don't
be a jerk about it don't you know try
we've all been jerks when it comes to
girls but try not to be and depending on
your age you might be a little old for
that anyway so you know find out what
what that person is and don't don't go
in saying I want to date because I need
a girlfriend and I want to get married
and me me me me me it's about the other
person go in enjoy it keep it fun if
dating isn't fun then I got nothing for
you you know that's the great
consolation of life do we have time for
one more one more okay is that enough
all right from Matthew Michael I really
enjoy the show and it has become my
favorite daily wire podcast yeah do you
hear that Ben
no he - Ben doesn't listen to this show
whenever I tell people about the daily
wire I always tell them I came for Ben
stayed for Michael thank you very much
anyway my question refers to the fall of
Adam and Eve more specifically is there
any extra biblical anthropological or
historical evidence to support the claim
of the fall
there were ones to first people who were
in a perfect state of grace
and would never have died had they not
sinned and disobeyed God if there is no
evidence for this how would we argue for
it to a secular person especially since
their argument from a Darwinian
perspective seems more tenable though it
does not explain the desire for meaning
and the fact we have a consciousness
yeah seems like a conundrum I look
forward to hearing your answer and keep
up the good work respectfully men so we
cannot know about the garden
we can't know about pre-fall everything
that we have in front of us is a product
of the fall our minds are a product of
the fall our you know we are in a fallen
world we are not we're not in a fallen
world that has a perfect place somewhere
in the middle of Iraq that's not how it
works we were kicked out of the garden
there is an angel with a flaming sword
so I have a few thoughts on all of this
broadly speaking if you're looking to
the Bible for science or you know
scientific history or scientific fact
you're looking in the wrong place I
think it was a carnal cardinal for where
I'm gonna get it wrong a cardinal
Boronia s-- wasn't maybe who knows I'll
look it up who said the Bible teaches us
how to go to heaven not how the heavens
go so just keep that in mind
nevertheless because the Bible contains
myth and history and poetry and history
and all of these things and journalism
and theology because it contains all of
these genres I know that the biblical
description of the creation is the most
precise and truthful way that I can
understand the creation of being of the
universe that's that is the most precise
way there were a more precise way if
there were a better way to do it God
would have told us in that way so I know
that for a fact
now I'm gonna violate what I just said
which is that I'll analyze it from an
anthropological or historical or
scientific perspective at CS Lewis did
this in some book I forget where maybe
it was Chesterton that the the fact of
the first person is a truism certainly
there was a first man there has to have
been because
even assuming you refer to it as the
Darwinian perspective and people abuse
that term endlessly but even assuming
that there was some sort of evolutionary
process some process of natural
selection at a certain point a
distinction was made between a beast who
is all instinct and a human being which
has intellect and will at a certain
point a distinction was made in a way
that we can imagine this is God reaching
down and touching Adam with God touching
the man and him having a consciousness
him having intellect and will and being
more than a grunting brute who is driven
only by instinct by definition that's
the first man so certainly that is the
case and so even if you want to follow
the evolutionary perspective or one of
the many evolutionary perspectives you
still have to butt up against that fact
of the first man
and but your understanding of it will be
much better if you focus on that
consciousness and what it means to be a
man and what the fall means and what it
means for us today as we live we live as
conscious beings with intellect and will
I hope that's I hope I was able to sum
up the creation of mankind in 20 seconds
they're not do you think I succeeded I
don't think I did but hopefully that
helps okay that's our show you've got a
binge another Kingdom season one because
we are vigorously recording season two
and it is very cool this is like we took
it up a notch for this new season and
the script of the new season is terrific
and the production quality is really
good so make sure you've been season one
written by the one and only Andrew
Clavin because we're gonna have season
two coming out very soon I will not tell
you when though okay that's our show see
on Monday I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show I'll see you next
week
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you